imaginez alors c'est comme dans le film
Les insaisissables de Christian géant un
huissier débarque chez vous vous faites
quoi
[Rires]
on va faire un truc alors je signale à
nos amis présents ici on peut bouger
pendant le jingle maintenant ah bon
[Applaudissements]
on bouge on fait quoi
[Musique]
ils ont tellement l'habitude de pas
bouger pendant le jingle que maintenant
ils arrivent à bouger pendant ce soir
exceptionnellement on peut bouger
pendant le jingle super conditionné
Thierry tu sais voilà alors donc c'est
une interview sans la bouche donc je
vais vous poser des questions et vous
allez me répondre sans parler c'est une
interview sans la bouche de quelle
humeur êtes-vous le matin quand vous
vous réveillez
oui d'accord
mais j'aimerais pas trop habiter avec
lui en même temps
quelle est la première chose que vous
faites en vous levant
quel est votre position préférée pour
prendre votre petit déjeuner
imaginons c'est un peu comme dans votre
livre là un couple de un couple de notre
temps là votre fille vous annonce
qu'elle est enceinte vous réagissez
comment
et si c'est votre fils qui vous annonce
qu'il est enceinte vous réagissez
comment
[Rires]
imaginaire c'est comme dans le film Les
insaisissables de Christian géant un
huissier débarque chez vous faites quoi
vous sortez dans la rue le matin il y a
un clochard qui vous demande le mode
vous lui donnez une petite pièce et il
vous dit que c'est pas assez vous
réagissez comment
le tout fonctionne vous arrivez sur le
tournage de la vérité 2 tout le monde
tout le monde se marre tout ça en vous
voyant vous savez pas pourquoi
d'accord pensez à quoi
alors au déjeuner il y a une figurine
qui vous drague
vous êtes du genre à couper court tout
de suite ou
vous rentrez chez vous et le clochard
vous insulte à nouveau puis n'oubliez
pas donné assez le matin votre femme
vous annonce qu'elle est enceinte de
l'huissier et vous vous pétez les plombs
c'est comment quand vous péter les
plombs je vais te montrerai tout à
l'heure
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu